now you said something that i find
fascinating which is that you looked at
other philanthropists and who had
a history of giving but your particular
experience which was
having been part of a startup right a
very successful one priceline
you brought a whole new set of skills
and talents that really wasn't part of
the conversation i would guess among the
people you were looking at or was it
uh no absolutely right um
we you know we were fortunate very
fortunate to be part of this first wave
of
uh of wealth creation um around the turn
of the century and when we went and
studied other families uh there were
families like the rockefeller family in
which we spent a lot of time meeting
family members of the rockefellers and
uh and actually um having advisors who
had worked with the rockefeller family
so we learned a lot from great families
and also learned lots from families that
perhaps were not as successful
in their philanthropy and also in their
families and i think your first question
is very important because with families
and family philanthropy there
there needs to be a connection between
the two and we've come across many
people where that isn't the case where
they're
you know excellent in philanthropy but
not necessarily paying attention to
their family and you have two children
two children what are their ages uh our
son drew is uh 22 and our daughter carly
is 20. just couple other sort of
demographic questions
uh
uh where did you go to school as a child
i grew up on long island uh and went to
uh elementary school and high school in
valley stream new york and what kind of
schools were they
they were basic long island public
schools public schools and betsy betsy
grew up in ithaca new york and uh
graduated from ithaca high school uh-huh
and uh did you ever do religious to go
to religious schools
yeah i you know i did there was a white
castle near where our uh temple was and
so we probably visited the white castle
as much as we visited the temple
and i think betsy had a similar
experience in her religion because one
of the fascinating things that
we
observe is
any contact
with
early
religious institutions seems to affect
people's giving do you think that that's
a connection or is it not in your case
no i don't i i don't think so i think
for both of us and we really are a team
and you'll hear
me mostly talk about we and us and if i
talk about i it's probably a mistake but
both of us
did not have a lot of religious training
but we grew up with families that were
strong families and i think with a sense
of uh that there was a bigger world out
there that we needed to participate in
and to give back and so it was very
natural for us when we realized that we
had an opportunity to do wonderful
things in the world to figure out how we
would make that happen